recently president biden announced that
serious long-term coven 19 cases could
qualify
under the federal disabilities act
meaning sufferers could qualify for
reasonable modifications at work or in
school as well
as our other health health care systems
now we're starting to understand a
little bit more
but there still aren't many medical
treatments for long-haul patients
denise joining us live in studio with a
promising new treatment right
yeah that's right there is a clinic in
the uk and it is treating long-haulers
worldwide by actually
resetting their brain the holistic
approach led by asuka gupta
caught the eye of covid sufferers after
a pilot study appeared in the journal of
clinical medicine
this is a real physical illness
with real physical symptoms ashook gupta
has spent decades treating people with
chronic conditions like fibromyalgia
his team focuses on treating and
resetting
the unconscious brain and now his clinic
is
crowded with long covered clients even
if the virus is no longer present
we can still feel severe symptoms so the
brain fog the breathlessness
it's intense fatigue and exhaustion
these are all down to an immune system
and nervous system that hasn't switched
off
it hasn't reset itself but it's
continuing to over respond
the technique is called neuroplasticity
that's the brain's ability to reorganize
itself
both functionally and physically gupta
believes it allows the neurons to
compensate for disease and injury and to
adjust to new experiences
think of it this way it might be
compared to how the brain reacts in a
post-traumatic stress situation
when we've fought off covid that has
been a survival response
and therefore this is like a
post-traumatic physiological response
it is different to ptsd but it may use
some of the same
neural networks and so anything that
reminds the brain of the original
infection
it will keep responding to and reacting
to
it starts with consistent training and
counseling but
rest sleep healthy diet reducing stress
are all vital to supporting the brain
and the body
for some it's enough to get back to
normal health
now gupta is in the midst now of a
randomized trial for long coveted
patients and hopes to have results
sometime later this year
meantime his program is available online
at guptapprogram.com
and you can read his clinical studies
and see testimonials of people worldwide
who have benefited from resetting their
brain